au printemps dernier marc isabelle
marchand et geneviève dubé ont attrapé
la co vide puis s'en sont débarrassés
s'est terminée pensait-elle leur
cauchemar débuté à peine
ça a commencé avec arrêt complet de la
voie des douleurs à me réveiller dans
les articulations des mots tête la
disney tachycardie gelé thorax dans un
étau pendant deux mois
j'avais de la difficulté avec mon
équilibre j'avais de la difficulté à
marcher
j'ai jamais été aussi malade de ma vie
ces femmes souffrent de ce qu'on appelle
maintenant le syndrome posco vide mais
quelques on remarque de plus en plus
fréquemment c'est que après la maladie
de covè après que le vert le virus est
plus détectable dans le corps au camp on
continue il ya des patients qui
continuent à avoir des symptômes
des études indiquent qu'au moins le
tiers des personnes infectées
développent ce syndrome
parmi les symptômes les plus fréquents
fatigue extrême douleur musculaire
difficultés respiratoires problèmes de
concentration anomalie cardiaque
ces cinq ans peut persister longtemps on
parle de plusieurs semaines même jusqu'à
plusieurs mois à date on sépare parce
que le virus est quand même nouveau mère
de quatre enfants geneviève dubé avait
l'habitude des marathons des triathlons
d2 lee hardman aujourd'hui elle courait
près son souffle présentement j'ai de la
difficulté à entretenir ma maison je
fais une activité e par jour à cause de
la fatigue à cause des symptômes qui
persistent
marc isabelle marchand pour sa part
abandonné le sport il vélo pour la
réadaptation
j'ai vu un pneumologue un cardiologue un
orl et ces gens m'ont conseillé
fortement de faire physio ergo et
beaucoup d'orthophonie elle fait des
progrès mais lentement et parfois elle
perd du terrain ce qui est un peu
décourageant ces personnes c'est comme
un temps ça va durer
personne si ce qu'est ce que vraiment on
a besoin des spécialistes reconnaissent
que le syndrome est encore mystérieux
ses loques la science est un peu en
retard parce qu'il faut on peut pas les
prévoir fait contre kas europe les
étudier on peut les comprendre on peut
pas vraiment les prévoir on sait que ce
n'est pas le virus lui même qui est
directement responsable syndrome qu'il
s'agirait plutôt des effets secondaires
de la violente attaque qu'il a fait
subir au corps humain
il ya des fois des causes indirectes ou
le système immunitaire le corps as en
apprenant à se défendre contre les virus
malheureusement peut se tromper de cible
pas juste attaqué le virus et attaquer
d'autres éléments du corps et ça c'est
toute la problématique des réactions
inflammatoires chroniques
on sait aussi que plusieurs autres virus
peuvent causer le même genre de problème
on peut voir si syndrome semblables
après l'infection avec un autre virus
qui causent le mono on peut le voir avec
d autres infections à antécédents
connaît on comprend dans l'histoire
l'histoire est humain et on voit les
mêmes symptômes de fatigue le titre qui
était respirer les difficultés consacrée
je considère que ça fait quatre mois que
je n'ai pas ma vie à moi je trouve selon
ça prend de la résilience de la patience
la persévérance que j'ai je dire du bien
reconnaît qu'elle a tiré le mauvais
numéro à le cri de la coved
elle espère seulement que son cas
servira d'exemple aux imprudents je
crois qu'on doit écouter les mesures la
santé publique parce qu'on peut pas
prendre la chance d'attraper ce virus le
parce qu'on le cpo qu'est ce qui va
faire comme dommages dans nos corps ou
dans le corps de la personne à côté nous
qui vole la trappe lis ici normand
grondin radio canada montréal